Well, I/O is already over. We hope you
had a great time and learned a lot
We're all done for now but... No no no no it's not over
at least not for you we're going to
create and publish 100 developer videos
in one hundred-days
100-day up Google-Dev!
We're going to inspire you to build Apps
gain users
and earn money across all your favorite
platforms
Android, iOS, the web and BEYOND!
We'll be delivering fresh new content all
summer long
inspiring you to Build Better Apps
no get
You'll get detailed information about our new products, pro tips for solving coding challenges
holders
and access to some Google's CRAZY new technologies!
so subscribe stay tuned to the Google
developers YouTube channel